hi i'm robert j lang origami artist and
physicist and today i've been challenged
to go through levels of complexity with
origami
[Music]
there's many ways to define complexity
for origami it could be the total number
of folds in the design it could be the
number of folds you have to bring
together at once i'm going to use a
combination of those two measurements
and illustrate it by going through
different levels of complexity in a
cicada one of the classic traditional
subjects of origami as a disclaimer this
is my interpretation of complexity as it
applies to origami
cicadas are very familiar in the
japanese culture in part because in
summertime they make a huge racket
not just in the countryside but even in
downtown tokyo the sound of cicadas can
be deafening within the origami world
they have a particular significance
because yoshizawa the great japanese
origami master considered his own cicada
to be his greatest creation and so many
origami artists have felt the need or
the desire
to create their own version of this
iconic insect my level one would be the
traditional japanese cicada
because it's one of the simplest folds
in all of origami it's just a handful
maybe one two three four five six seven
eight steps all simple folds and yet it
reads very strongly as a cicada this can
be folded by almost anyone in just a few
minutes it consists of nothing but
valley folds the simplest fold in all of
origami although it only has a handful
of folds there's a few places where you
can put your personal stamp on it by
making judgment folds folds that don't
have a specific reference point in
particular the angle at which you fold
down the wings and then the angles at
which you fold down these two corners on
the top are done pretty much by eye by
adjusting those folds positions a person
can adjust the character and the
finished shape of their cicada for level
two this is a little bit more
complicated because it incorporates a
few more judgment folds but notably it
has a fold called a petal fold that
petal fold is built from
two folds called swivel folds we'll
start the same way in fact this will be
based pretty much on the traditional
cicada but now we want to do a few
things differently we'd like to make the
wings longer if i fold it down with a
valley fold that's all the length i can
get from my wing but if i'm willing to
do a more complicated fold i can get
longer wings
and that more complex fold is called a
swivel fold and so what with my more
complicated fold
i'm going to move it down and create
this little pocket
which i will then flatten
when i fold the flap down i'll have to
fold it
underneath
the pocket
formed here
but if i do that
fold it down
and then
tuck some of it underneath and that's a
mountain fold
and then the last little bit
as i fold
valley fold down but then fold the paper
back
i'm going to leave a little bit of color
exposed here
and the reason i'll do that
is that when i then
fold the edges
inside
same as i did before
my cicada
will have colored eyes
so although this is still quite stylized
geometric and a little bit abstract i
think it's closer to the form of a real
cicada it reads a little bit better as a
cicada
for level three we're still doing a
fairly simple abstract cicada but
we've added a few more folds of
complexity and we've added some squash
folds which allow us to shape the wings
relative to the abdomen and give a
little bit more of a teardrop shape
which matches the wing shape over an
actual cicada i'll do
a squash fold lift a flap up i put my
finger inside
press it flat that's a new fold it
actually combines making multiple folds
because i'm creating a fold here and
here at the same time that i'm bringing
it down
it's a combination fold
but that allows us to achieve a little
bit
more shaping
we're adding what are called crimp folds
which let us both create distinct eyes
and also give the body a little bit of
three-dimensional roundedness so i'm
gonna do a crimp that's putting a valley
and a mountain right next to each other
and the mirror image on the back side
so there's the crimp on the front
do the same on the back
press them to set the crimp
and then
i'm going to fold
corners underneath
which will lock the crimp in place
and then that also allows me to open the
model out
as we add details to the origami design
we travel along a continuum from
abstract to highly realistic this is my
level four design which is a cicada
designed by the great akira yoshizawa
from this point onward the folding is
sufficiently complex that i'm not going
to fold them from start to finish but
i'll fold through until we can see the
base and the basic structure the reason
we have such a big jump from three to
four is we're going from representations
without legs the representations with
legs a cicada has six legs so our number
of legs needs to make a big jump right
there go from zero to six so just as we
need to make a big jump in the number of
legs we'll also need to make a big jump
in the complexity of folding this level
four design by yoshizawa he used a
rectangle that takes eight bird bases
and put them together into a rectangle
this is the crease pattern
for the bird base and you see this
star-shaped motif
and that little star-shaped motif is
repeated eight times
in this crease pattern
that when folded looks like this
so a row of two across and eight along
makes it possible to fold this
fairly complex base but that has enough
flaps to get all of the legs as well as
the wings and other features of the
cicada
this is my level 5 design it's a cicada
that i developed back in the 1980s
it coincidentally shares a lot of its
structure with yoshizawa's and that it's
built from a rectangle that has an array
of bird-based patterns but the next step
in this march of realism will be to put
in the antenna even though the antenna
are quite small on a cicada they're
definitely noticeable and so we do that
by adding two more bird bases to the
pattern in the rectangle make the
rectangle a little bit longer add a few
more features and then we can get
antenna as well as eyes wings and legs
so one of the steps up in creating the
base we have to fold some layers
together and then unwrap one layer
that's that's wrapped around another
this layer is wrapped around another
and then
i unwrap it
so that it comes down
and this layer
gets turned up
that gives another base that's pretty
similar to the yoshizawa base
but it has
two long flaps and crucially
the addition
of two small points one here
and one here and so this step of
unwrapping is the next step in this
sequence of cicada designs this is my
level six now even though rectangles
started to become pretty common in the
60s and 70s the 1980s in the world of
origami people felt like it was an
aesthetically desirable thing to use
squares most traditional origami designs
came from squares
there's a certain geometric elegance to
a square so even though rectangles
allowed us to create more complex shapes
with like cicadas with legs and antenna
we thought
can we do that
from a square but getting points like
legs long skinny appendages that come
from the interior of the paper require
quite a bit more in the way of both
planning and design and also in the
complexity of the folding steps
themselves
this design used some additional folds
we haven't seen yet called rabbit ear
folds and they're pretty easy but it
also required a fold called a closed
unwrap and a closed sink and these are
now quite famous in the world of origami
for their difficulty
i wrap a layer from back to front
these are pretty difficult to do
without ripping the paper it's called a
closed sink i'm going to put this point
inside
in a way
that locks the edges together
and i have to do that
by
opening it up
a little bit
and then
re-folding and when i'm done
the point is gone
and there's a little pocket and the
edges are locked together but the reason
we use them is it allows us to create
combinations of points and flaps that in
this case will give us the legs that we
want from a square
this is my level seven design and we can
also do a side by side to this one to
see how
things improve
but it's folded completely differently
from level six one of the things we'd
like to do to increase the realism is to
make all of the legs very thin and
delicate have none of them come from the
interior of the paper but the only way
to ensure that happens is to start
planning the design from the beginning
so that the legs don't come from the
center and to do that we use a new
technique called circle packing in which
all of the long features of the design
are represented by circles so each leg
becomes a circle each wing becomes a
circle and things that can be big and
thick like the head or the abdomen can
be points in the middle the basic folds
of origami like mountains and valley
folds have had names
for years even decades and some of the
other combinations of two or three
mountains and valleys have also been
given names like reverse fold or rabbit
ear
but as we move up the level of
complexity we find that we need to start
putting together groups of folds in
unique ways that have never been done
before and so these folds don't even
have names because you might not
encounter that exact combination ever
again
but in many cases these new combinations
of folds arise when we're trying to
create a new point from somewhere in the
interior of the paper and that happened
in this design which bumps its level of
complexity up one more than the previous
this is level eight shizuoka cicada it's
one step up from level seven
because it has
even thinner more delicate legs
and
more graceful teardrop shaped wings
this required yet another new design in
all the previous designs we could fold
the model sequentially start with a
square do one step at a time maybe do a
few folds at a time but we could break
the folds down into a sequence but in
some designs you might have tens or even
hundreds of folds that all have to come
together at once
and when that happens we call that a
collapse
[Music]
i've got my six legs here
two flaps
four wings a long flap for the body
these cross pleats would be used to
segment the body and then some extra
paper up here for the head and i can use
these corners to create an antenna
and there's our finished shizuka cicada
for my level 9 version of a cicada i
thought we would move to a juvenile
cicada because it has some additional
features that demand additional
complexity one is that a nymph cicada
has proportionately longer legs
so we need to get longer flaps
but we still have to make them very very
skinny
but most notably
it has a lot more structure on the claws
it's got a pointed front claw and then a
spine at the base of each claw we can
also add segments distinct segments for
the abdomen to make this happen
we go again to the technique of
box pleating or square packing and this
time we'll have a lot more little
figures a lot more squares a lot more
objects to pack to get all these small
features the spines the eyes the scale
that gives rise to a more complex crease
pattern one that has more folds and then
that fold too
requires a collapse to bring it all
together we have a square or a rectangle
for every little pointy bit on the shape
so we have little squares for the spines
little squares for the claws large ones
for the legs small ones for the antenna
and so forth and we have to pack all of
those into the square and then from that
packing we construct the crease pattern
that has not only more up and down and
side to side folds and that therefore
gives rise to this crease pattern with
more folds and a more complicated
collapse
this is my level 10 design which is a
flying cicada and what makes this more
complex now is that it has
four major flaps that come from the
interior of the paper
head flap abdomen and two of the legs
the reason we need those extra flaps is
because now it's flying we need four
really large flaps to make the wings
cicadas have four wings
four large wing flaps
are take up most of the side edges of
the paper and so then we have to get
other features from the interior of the
square the folds that generate those
middle points are harder they're more
complex and the fact that we have four
of them now more than we've ever had
before is what puts this
into the next level of complexity
my level 11 design is a cicada we're
back to the classic pose
but this
deceptively simple design
actually has the most complex folds of
everything we've done before just in
terms of the design this is actually a
step backward in complexity because it's
just an array of bird bases but in terms
of the complexity of actually folding
this is the most complex of anything
that we've looked at it contains closed
sinks
mixed sinks
mixed wraps combinations of all these
folds and a very large number of them so
many many individual folds those middle
points
require
much more complex folds than any of the
steps that we've done leading up to this
and that's what makes this the highest
level in this series
those are my levels of complexity you
might have your own levels for origami
or whatever your past time might be i
want to thank wired for giving me this
opportunity
and wish all of you happy folding